listen Mother's Day is coming you ever
sit there you're cooking you go to your
mother's house your brothers are there
your sister's there maybe your sister's
got a [__] boyfriend he's a loser he
beats around the weekends you don't
know you don't know but while your mom's
cooking you're looking at her ass you
ever catch a look at your mom's ass and
ask yourself what do you think your
mom's ass smells like you ever take that
thought youever take that to a Next
Level just look at your mom's ass next
time and go
I would hate to sniff that [__] and
[__] right
now my mother's dead God forbid oh my
God
but Mother's Day is
coming why take the chance you don't
want your mom to have a stinky ass hole
what if she goes to Bingo and she gets
picked up by a Latin lover and he dips
into a [__] Muffler and it stinks
like the pens and fruit cocktail is that
what you want your mother's ass so to
smell like [__] no look like
[Music]
oh my God your mother the bed of back
[__] listen hello tushy.com portable
bedday fit in your bathroom my God
you'll never feel better that you ever
did before in your life you'll feel
confident you leave the house no more
[__] toilet paper there's no trees
getting [__] up in the jungles you're
just living off water they also have
little towels available that you can
wash and dry later on you just sprinkle
that little water into your little
Muffler it takes away all the little
[__] stenia and lettuce and God knows
what else is hanging from your nasty
mother's [__] you understand me this
is why go to hell tushi.com right now
and press in church bam Church CH Hui C
10% off a PTI for b day for Mother's Day
trust me this weekend when you go to
your mother's to eat look at her ass
ask yourself would I lick that [__]
thing for the small 20 no you
would cuz you know it smells like a
[__] Billy goat's [__] give it a
Beday listen you avoid a bunch of stuff
it clean the colon it cleans all the
[__] things that are in there anyway
do me a favor why [__] around and talk
about the disease of the [__] I'm
trying to sprinkle humor into this ad
here do yourself a favor go to
hellotushy.com right now and press in
Church bam 10% off portable devices
60-day money back guarantee it's like
having a [__] spit living in your
toilet just spitting up into your
[__] you know what that feeling is
like no you don't you want that feeling
go to hellotushy.com right now and press
in church boom